[Musica]
dato che oggi parliamo di favolosa
complessità ho deciso di raccontarvi la
mia esperienza della complessità Come
fosse una favola E come tutte le favole
che si rispettino ci sono eroi eroine
difficoltà da superare e l'immancabile
lieto fine
e da ultimo la morale della favola
l'insegnamento che possiamo trarre
il titolo della favola che vi racconto È
il coraggio di vivere la complessità
avevo 35 anni ero dottore commercialista
le visure contabile avevano uno studio
tutto mio ben avviato nella mia città in
cui ho fatto ritorno dopo diversi anni e
vivevo con la persona che amava
avevo raggiunto tutti gli obiettivi che
mi ero prefissata allora
una relazione d'amore felice la casa
appena comprata
uno studio ben avviato molti clienti un
buon reddito
e devo dire che avevo faticato molto per
arrivarci prima all'università Poi
l'esame di stato e poi diversi anni di
pratiche presso altri studi come sapete
spesso sottopagati
entro soddisfatta del lavoro che facevo
perché mi dava
grande autonomia cosa che io desideravo
moltissimo e poi mi gratificava sentirmi
riconosciuto come professionista lo devo
ammettere mi piaceva sentirmi chiamata
dottoressa
Eppure
ero molto stanca A volte esausta e Certe
sere quando tornavo a casa dallo studio
mi sentivo svuotata come se tutte le mie
energie fossero state risucchiate dentro
di me dal lavoro di quella giornata
e non riuscivo ad avere i bambini
i medici a cui vengono rivolte Mi
avevano consigliato di fare delle cure
ormonali
con un probabile gemellare e forse
probabilmente anche una gravidanza
assistita una prospettiva che
sinceramente non è che mi entusiasma
molto
poi avvenne quello che in termini di
complessità potremmo chiamare un innesco
l'innesco è come il fiammifero che può
scatenare un incendio
andata e un medico che conoscevo da anni
un antroposopo non so se conoscete
questo termine
andremo da lui quando non riusciva a
curarmi con la medicina tradizionale e
proprio perché era un antroposofà aveva
una visione più integrata del rapporto
tra mente corpo di quanto
avessero mostrato gli altri medici a cui
me lo rivolta e dopo la visita lui mi ha
detto che
se volevo veramente avere un figlio
avrei dovuto smettere di fare il lavoro
che facevo
che bloccava tutte le mie energie a
livello mentale assorbendole
completamente
e che sarei dovuto andare a coltivare la
terra a fare l'agricoltore insomma
letteralmente a mettere le mani nella
terra e forse dopo un anno sarei anche
potuto rimanere incinta
avevo toccato un punto molto debole
dentro di me forse la mia parte più
vulnerabile io fino a quel momento avevo
scelto solo strade che erano già state
segnate da altri
erano dritte sicure come le strade di
una città
e anche il lavoro che facevo per quanto
è vero mi stressava e mi stancava però
mi dava grandi certezze io sapevo molto
bene cosa fare come ero brava nel loro
che facevano
e' anche vero che vedo ammetterlo che io
il mio compagno sognavamo un giorno
effettivamente di andare a vivere la
natura sognavamo di
avere un piccolo pezzo di terra magari
un piccolo orto qualche albero da frutto
qualche ulivo proprio stavamo di fare
una volta andati in pensione Insomma
quando avremo smesso di lavorare da
anziani
e invece lui mi stava suggerendo che
potevo cambiare radicalmente la mia vita
andare a fare un lavoro che non avevo
mai fatto di cui non sapevo nulla
in un luogo che non sapevo nemmeno quale
sarebbe potuto essere
una scommessa totale e devo dirlo
veramente un'incertezza totale
Ma se avesse avuto ragione
quanto tempo potevo ancora aspettare
prima di decidermi ad avere un figlio e
prima di decidermi quindi di abbandonare
casa lavoro città per provarci
e avevo già 35 anni Lo so che sembra
un'età Giovane ma in realtà come donna
sappiamo che non abbiamo molto tempo
davanti a noi per provare ad avere una
gravidanza
e l'innesco è vero che può accendere e
fa scoppiare degli incendi ma a me
Almeno procurò una valanga di domande
senza risposta
Se non ci fossi riuscita e se avessi
sbagliato tutto e poi
sapevo mica se sarei stata capace di
farlo
e poi che mi assicurava che veramente
sarei rimasta incinta
e poi la domanda più difficile di tutte
avevo il coraggio di cambiare
radicalmente la mia vita avevo il
coraggio di rinunciare
comunque a quello che avevo costruito
fino a quel momento che mi dava
tranquillità certezza serenità
prospettive per il futuro
Insomma avevo una paura terribile di
sbagliare tutto
ho deciso abbiamo deciso i miei compagni
insieme di farlo lo stesso di provarci
di fare un salto insieme nel buio
ma sapendo che
l'unica certezza che avevamo era che non
saremmo mai più potuti tornare indietro
e ho capito che il coraggio non è agire
senza avere paura e agire nonostante la
paura
del resto se non ci fosse la paura il
coraggio non avrebbe nemmeno ragione di
esserci di provarlo
e mi sono anche resa conto che spesso
coraggio e follia Vanno a braccetto O
almeno quello che altri osservando
quello che stavo facendo che stavamo
facendo giudicavano una vera e propria
follia
e adesso chiedo
a ognuno di voi
provate per un attimo a tornare un
momento della vostra vita in cui vi
siete trovati anche voi
di fronte alla necessità di dover fare
delle scelte radicali improvvise in cui
non sapevate nulla di quello che avesse
trovato prendendo quella strada
Eppure avevate ben chiaro invece cosa vi
sareste dovuti lasciare alle spalle
per scegliere un'altra strada
una strada che corsa da pochi Forse da
nessuno
Qual è stato il vostro innesco e quali
paura Avete provato
Quali domande vi siete fatti
Questa è l'incertezza
e se avete comunque scelto quel sentiero
nascosto
che mi spaventava tantissimo ma che pure
al tempo stesso ti stava chiamando
e questo il momento dedicato al coraggio
così lo abbiamo fatto
Ho passato i clienti dello studio a una
giovane collega Abbiamo venduto casa
Abbiamo trovato il luogo che ci ispirava
25 ettari di terreni abbandonati da più
da 50 anni in uno stato pietoso coperto
di rovi
e circondati da più di 70 ettari di
boschi
non so se avete un'idea ma sono un
milione di metri quadrati di terra
un'enormità
e
sono diventate imprenditrice agricola La
coltivatrice diretta ho trovato
consulente ed esperti che mi potessero
consigliare su cosa fare come
e bisognava fare tutto bisognava
ripulire terreni altrimenti la
coltivazione
piantare L'Oliveto l'orto Il Vigneto
allevare gli animali Ma poi mancava
anche l'acqua bisognava portare l'acqua
dappertutto trovare vecchie fonti
riprese di sentire di fare persino la
strada per arrivarci
E così ho cominciato a pianificare Tutto
come deve essere mia abitudine quindi
prendevo dei grandissimi fogli sui quali
disegnavi terreni e li suddividevo in
coltivazioni da fare rotazione e tempi
di semina a tempi di raccolta Insomma un
po' Come erano le tabelle cosa vuoi per
fare i bilanci quando stavo ancora nello
studio
Eppure eppure le cose non funzionavano
granché era molto difficile decidere che
cosa coltivare e come su quali terreni
erano tutti diversi avevano pendenze
diverse esposizioni al sole diverse
forme diverse composizioni del terreno
stesso diverso
Come facevo a pianificare tutto e anche
i consulenti per quanto esperte in
realtà facevano
dei gravi errori in qualche modo di
previsione
vi faccio qualche esempio giusto per
darvi un'idea e il primo autunno ci
hanno consigliato di piantare 1.200
piante di ulivo
in realtà poi erano piccoline così una
volta messe a terra
evitato l'inverno ha nevicato hai
nevicato tanto la coperta e quindi sono
morti tutti allora in primavera ci hanno
consigliato di piantare 1.200 alberi da
frutto che erano più resistenti al
freddo lasciando pascolare le pecore che
avevamo perché tanto non avrebbero fatto
nessun danno perché erano senza foglie
Peccato però che l'estate successiva non
morti tutti anche loro perché le pecore
in realtà avevano mangiato la corteccia
degli alberi facendoli morire
Insomma io non riuscivo a capire cosa
c'era che non stavo capendo Cioè cosa
c'era che non stava funzionando dove era
che stava sbagliando
poi una notte ho fatto un sogno
Breve e intenso
andavo sul terreno appena nato pronto
per la semina grandissimo
e minchinavo per appoggiare l'orecchio
sulla terra
ti ascoltavo
sentivo Ciò che quella terra voleva
dirmi
Quali erano le piante che volevano
nascere
Qual era la bellezza che avrebbe voluto
mostrare
Qual era la vita che voleva germogliare
Io ho sentito per la prima volta in
tutta me stessa
una cosa che non ho mai sentito prima in
maniera così forte
che era lo strumento per rendere
visibile
quello che ancora non si era manifestato
e che il mio compito era facilitato quel
processo agevolarlo aiutarlo ma non
controllarlo non guidarlo
coltivare e prendersi cura con pazienza
e perseveranza saper aspettare che ciò
che hai seminato e piantato possa
mettere radici prendere vita
e mostrarsi nella sua straordinaria
bellezza
in fondo se ci pensate
e come avere un figlio
e in effetti
lo ripeto Il Frutteto Il Vigneto l'orto
hanno messo radici
hanno preso vita e si sono manifestati
nella loro straordinaria bellezza
e vivere Proprio questo è trasformarsi
in strumenti in cassa di risonanza di
qualcosa che è ancora non si è
manifestato e aiutarlo a renderlo
manifesto
sentire che noi e la terra e tutti gli
esseri siamo
interdipendenti
siamo parte di un unico processo che
genera continuamente La vita
e adesso chiedo a voi per l'ultima volta
Provate a tornare a un momento della
vostra vita in cui vi siete sentiti di
essere parte di qualcosa di più grande
che trascendeva voi stessi e la vita di
tutti i giorni
un momento in cui avete sentito di
essere al servizio della vita nella sua
espressione della sua bellezza
uno strumento utile che
in qualche modo aiuta a svelare qualcosa
che senza di voi non si sarebbe mai
potuto manifestare
Questa è l'interdipendenza
ed è questo il momento dedicato alla
vita
[Applauso]
però devo dirvi devo dirvi che è vero
che la complessità è faticosa
è faticosa da capire ed è difficile da
accettare
noi parliamo di abbracciarla viverla
attraversarla
Eppure richiede uno sforzo enorme
non solo dobbiamo studiarla Qualcuno lo
sa bene dobbiamo pensarci dobbiamo
rifletterci sopra ma dobbiamo anche
sentirla dentro di noi provare
l'emozione profonda di essere dentro la
complessità di esserne parte
E tutto questo
Bisogna dire anche questo bisogna
metterlo tutto questo al solo scopo di
rinunciare alle certezze di rinunciare a
soluzioni semplici e veloci
Ma perché farlo in fondo che bisogna c'è
per di farlo Cioè chi Ci obbliga a farlo
Ed ecco la morale della favola
Ci sono momenti in cui è necessario
inchinarsi e ascoltare con umiltà
lasciare andare le certezze lasciala
andare il controllo
lasciare andare le soluzioni semplici e
veloci
e aprirci all'altro lato della nostra
vita
l'incertezza l'interdipendenza
e questo il momento dedicato alla
complessità
e non importa su quali strade dritte
stiamo andando non importa quale bivio
stiamo evitando
la complessità ci segue ad ogni passo ad
ogni scelta Ad ogni azione che facciamo
per poterci sorprendere a volte con dei
doni meravigliosi per questo ci vuole il
coraggio di vivere la complessità
[Applauso]
in effetti
dopo un anno aspettavo Francesco e dopo
due anni aspettava Andrea
la complessità a volte sa essere
favolosa Grazie
[Applauso]